talk a little bit about biogeochemical
cycles and the term biogeochemical
sounds very fancy but really these are
just cycles that involve different
molecules that are essential for life
and how they circulate through an
ecosystem and really how they circulate
through the entire through an entire
biosphere and the molecules that we care
about and molecules they could consist
of one element or multiple elements they
are things like well water molecules h2o
oxygen and hydrogen make up a lot of
living a lot of living creatures a lot
of biomass and and water is just an
essential element that is involved in
life as we know it we're also going to
be talking about carbon and carbon takes
on many forms when we think about
biogeochemical cycles there's carbon
dioxide in the air there's a lot of
carbon inorganic molecules that form up
most of the mass of life as we know it
and then there's actors that maybe don't
get as much attention there are things
like nitrogen and of course you have
characters like characters like
phosphorus and you might say okay I get
that most organic molecules are made up
of a bunch of carbons and hydrogen's and
every now and then oxygens but what
about nitrogen's and what about
phosphorous and remember your DNA
deoxyribonucleic acid we're talking
about nitrogenous bases your Adnan's and
guanine and all of these things that we
talked about in DNA they involve
nitrogen and there's other biomolecules
amino acids proteins amino acids which
make up proteins that involve nitrogen
phosphorus ATP the the identity tri
phosphate it's essential it's an in that
in that core biomolecule it's also in
the backbone of DNA so these are all
essential elements for life and the key
thing is is that they all get recycled
through biogeochemical cycles so they
are all recycled we talked about how an
ecosystem energy flows it might start
with light energy from the Sun and then
over time as it's transferred from one
form to another as it flows
one form to another it gets dissipated
as heat but the matter the elements the
molecules here this is recycled it was
originally formed I mean there's a few
meteorites that hit every now and then
but the foot most part most of the
matter around us was here at the dawn of
when the earth was first formed it was
first created in the in the inside due
to fusion reactions of stars billions
and billions and billions of years ago
so all of life everything that we've
seen so so far in the history of Earth
for the most part is just the same
elements and the same molecules that
have been recycled over and over and
over again and so when we think about
biogeochemical cycles we will think
about things like if we're talking about
h2o we're going to think about the water
cycle water cycle and we have a whole
video on that but in vist the short
version of it is you could have water
actually stored into multiple different
ways some of it can evaporate as water
vapor eventually it condenses in the
form of clouds and then it can rain back
down and along the way you can have
animals get access especially to the
fresh water and make that part of the
actual living organisms you actually
also have living organs that view the
water as part of their ecosystem but we
go into some depth in another video
you'll also hear people talk about if
we're talking about carbon the carbon
cycle the carbon cycle and just as a
very high-level overview of the carbon
cycle so let's say that's the ground
let's say that this is a plant right
over here it's a primary producer an
autotroph we talked about that in our
ecosystem video so let me draw a leaf
here this is a plant that is growing
what it's doing while it takes light
energy so it gets light energy from the
Sun so that's the light energy right
over there and it uses that light energy
to fix carbon the carbon that is making
up this plant it's just not emerging out
of nowhere it's being recycled it's
being recycled from carbon molecules
that are
in the air so the carbon molecules in
the air they are going to be or the
carbon in the air it's going to be in
molecular form in terms it's going to be
carbon dioxide so that over there is co2
and so the plant uses that light energy
and that gaseous that co2 gas and it's
able to fix the carbon to construct it
so it looks like that plant is just
growing it's not clear where all that
mass is coming from but it literally is
coming from the air and it might be able
to get it might get a few of the
nutrients especially things like
nitrogen phosphorus from the ground and
that's where we could go into the whole
nitrogen and phosphorous cycles but then
once these plants fix all of this carbon
some of it it gets stored in the biomass
sometimes the plant dies and then it
gets buried and then with enough
pressure it can turn into hydrocarbons
so hydrocarbons when you fuel your car
it's really it's really energy stored by
dead plants a long long time ago that
got buried and put into that form but it
was essentially plants through
photosynthesis that first store that
energy but then of course and we talked
about this you can have animals that eat
those plants so let me draw an animal
that is eating it so that looks like an
animal well that one looks like
something that likes to eat more than
just plants so this is weed right like
it's like an alligator chicken looking
thing well that's close enough well you
get the idea what it eats that plant
it's using some of that carbon that was
fixed originally by that plant for its
own biomass but also as it as it
metabolizes
the some of it is that it will use that
the the bond the energy stored in those
chemical bonds to to live and grow and
move about and as it does that it will
it will exhale the co2 so that the co2
goes back into the environment and this
is a huge oversimplification of the
carbon cycle but this is the general
idea and eventually this thing might die
or might get eaten by other other
consumers and then you have the
decomposers down here who could further
make use of those chemical bonds that
the primary producer first created using
that light energy let me
deke um decomposers right over here and
they might also
as they consume that release more co2
which will eventually then get fixed
again by a primary producer and there's
similar cycles for nitrogen and
phosphorus these often involving
bacteria to fix the nitrogen in the
phosphorus from the air to make it
available as nutrients in the soil for
some of the primary producers in say the
carbon cycle and nitrogen doesn't get a
lot of attention but this is actually
the most common gas in our atmosphere so
it's all around you right now even while
we're breathing we are breathing a lot
of nitrogen although it doesn't play as
strong of a role as say oxygen and the
oxygen in the air is going to be
molecular oxygen so I could also write
oh - right over here or as we breathe
out carbon dioxide so I could write see
co2 co2 right over there but hopefully
this gives you a sense of how matter is
recycled as energy is flowing through
ecosystems including the largest
ecosystem on earth which is earth as a
biosphere you have matter being
constantly recycled and the the cycle of
that matter we call biogeochemical
cycles I think I just said the word
cycle a lot